i mean it's hard for me to get custody
it's easy for men to be seen as the
aggressor um in the video that you
reviewed i said um
you know a lot of the modern day women
will if they feel aggrieved by a man
will you know act as if they want to
fight him
yeah you know i've seen a lot of women
up in men's faces like they want to
fight and i'm
sitting there thinking
really do you really want to do that but
the only the only reason why a woman can
do that is because if she knows there's
a system designed
to to always see her as the victim yeah
because if a man was going to even raise
his voice or
you know push her or whatever the man
would all will automatically be seen as
the aggressor whereas she could be up in
his face you know pointing in his head
you know doing all that kind of stuff
and it's like he's just got to sit there
and take it which is enough which is
another emasculation process for the man
it's like how much you're supposed to
stand here and allow someone not just a
woman or a man but a person
to talk to me in a way that you know i
don't want to be spoken to and
physically touch me the way i don't want
to be physically touched but if i was to
retaliate i'd have the police at my door
you know i mean like in hangar
i mean so it's like
yeah there's a lot of things within the
society that
um
need to be addressed i think can men let
not call the police on a woman like can
girls
yeah i mean they can but as a man being
a man myself yeah it doesn't run through
my head to call the police on a woman
unless she's really like i don't know
smashing windows or i don't know doing
something like really crazy
but generally men don't meant don't
feel the need to call
uh the police which is why a lot of men
uh are in abusive relationships with
women and no one knows
yeah well that's another thing that i
had no idea about i didn't know either
that a lot of girls will like leverage
the kids like if um
if like a they have a kid together and
they break up and then the guy doesn't
like act the way she wants or do what
she wants like the girls will literally
like
like
not let the dad see the kids yeah um and
i'm just wondering like how is that
legal
um
because okay so i talk about parental
alienation yeah and one of the um
one of the major things in parental
alienation is to demonize
the father
so that when you're speaking to people
they say oh yeah i can definitely see
why you're keeping him away from his
child so a lot of parents
who have a parent who wants to alienate
their child will say he's an abuser i
don't know he's a narcissist he's he
sexually assaulted her he physically
assaulted her um
she stalks her she's scared of him you
know all this kind of stuff and so this
is how it becomes quite easy
as a matter of fact because if a woman
says that about a man she'll get
believed nine times out of ten yeah you
know um and that's not to say that
doesn't happen because if it does it's
not it's an unfortunate thing yeah but
not every
that is why it is so easy
to um alienate a father from their child
because the woman can say he done x y
zed
and she'll be believed
so
and there's not really any repercussions
if she lies about something is there
no
like i i can't imagine it's like super
common that a guy like presses charges
on a girl for lying about like abuse or
nurse like like that sort of thing i
want to say narcissism but you can't you
can't charge someone
i mean i made a video a couple of days
ago called what is a rapist
yeah um and
i made that video because there's a guy
in the uk he plays he plays for a major
football team and he's been accused of
rape
and
he's been accused of rape
he hasn't been convicted of rape
and so one of my things is how how come
men that get accused of rape
have their whole life plastered all over
the media
whereas we don't know who's accusing him
and i'm not saying he isn't a rapist he
could be
but he's not convicted of a crime yet so
why do we know
all of his business and it's like i
think that's very unfair because the
term rape and your name go together and
people don't care anymore they don't
care whether you're innocent or whether
you're guilty they just oh yeah he's a
rapist
and so you can get trialed by media and
i was saying that that's a very unfair
thing so if women are found to be lying
or there's insufficient evidence they're
not going to be tried they're not going
to be charged they're not going to be
you know convicted of any crime but they
just get to you know say something and
walk away whereas a man's life can be
totally you know totally um
discombobulated after that do you think
if there's a lack of sufficient evidence
the woman should be tried then like she
should go to court
um
i don't think so because sometimes if
there's lack of physical evidence then
it doesn't mean there was no assault do
you know what i mean i think if someone
is found to be actually lying
about it then
yeah
i think they should be tried and i never
understood like the believe all women
um
like notion because i know some girls
that like dude that lie about literally
everything right so like how can you say
to believe
50 of the population just undoubtedly
that doesn't make any sense but then a
lot of women know that they'll be
believed as well yeah
do you know what i mean and so it
creates a
one of what what we're talking about it
creates a very
psychopathic
narcissistic
egotistical type person when you know
that you can lie and be believed you
know imagine you had that power imagine
i could say anything to you and i i knew
people are going to believe me like i
could abuse that wholeheartedly abuser
and um that's not me saying that all
women are like this but i'm saying
because the environment in which we live
um
champions certain behaviors and
behaviors it's very easy to do that
well i always say like it gets rid of
the consequence so like i i think people
are more likely to do bad things if
there's no consequence
so like what what consequence does she
really have even like
even people that go to court and they're
not found guilty like
they still will like girls still can
like write a book and make a career out
of like one accusation
off of like a big name celebrity like
what what incentive is that to stop
doing
it um there is no real incentive yeah
and that's the thing there is no real
incentive and so
you know what what generally happens
when i speak the way i speak you know a
lot of women
say oh you hate women and
you're a misogynist and you're a toxic
masculinity
and i'm like no like someone has to
balance this thing out now this thing
has got to be balanced out i think you
know me trying to like i talk a lot
about um
red pill rage you like the red pill
community have a lot there's a lot of
angry men in the regular community right
um
and so
when it comes to you know women
and the way they read some of the red
pills see women they're like this and
women are that i hate them
and and people try to you know i guess
put me in the same category and it's
like no you can get people in the red in
the red pill community and the
manosphere who were quite level-headed
but they just need to
rectify the balance of
the overcorrection that happened for the
five for the past five decades
yeah well i think that's why like
people watch my channel um because i
don't know how much you've seen but i
literally
just react to red pill content right yes
and so people aren't really used to
seeing like a girl watch it and not get
offended and like mad
but yeah i mean
a lot of women do though yeah and that's
the thing i think but then i think i've
always i've made so many different
videos um because i made one on what i
would call
i really are you allowed to
curse on this channel i hope so i don't
know
no i
i could i had a video called uh this
[ __ ] made generation yeah and um
literally this generation in my point of
view
is just over-emotional it's like they're
waiting to be offended by something it's
like they go around the internet
looking for things to be offended by and
then as soon as they're offended by it
they start flagging it and trying to
cancel people you know i mean trying to
make petitions and it's just like yo
like when did we get this sensitive i
don't understand